la conscience démocratique des français
malgré l'incident diplomatique en
tanzanie
le voyage de luigi ragona frais une
réussite sur le fond le calme est revenu
à memphis où elvis presley a été inhumé
la nuit dernière radio à la coccinelle
and i lady de walt disney bonsoir
monsieur giscard d'estaing se rendra en
corse
la date n'est pas encore fixée le voyage
se fera le moment venu a précisé le
porte parole de l'elysée à l'issue de
l'entretien qu'a eu le chef de l'état
aujourd'hui avec les deux préfet de la
corse en présence du ministre de
l'intérieur
il s'agira alors d'examiner avec les
élus et la population
la solution de leurs difficultés dans un
meilleur climat
voici d'ailleurs la déclaration du chef
de l'état par la voix de jean philippe
lecat
le président de la république a reçu en
présence de monsieur christian bonnet
ministre de l'intérieur les préfets de
la corse du sud et de la haute-corse
il leur a indiqué chargé par mes
fonctions de veiller à l'unité de la
république et à l'application des lois
je vous invite à vous inspirer de ces
deux principes pour mettre fin des
actions inadmissible et pour permettre à
la population corse de vivre comme elles
le souhaitent dans la dignité et la
sécurité
la fréquence des élections démocratiques
assurent aux pouvoirs publics d
interlocuteur qualifié
c'est donc avec les élus municipaux
départementaux et régionaux que vous
devez examiner résoudre les problèmes
qui se posent dans les départements
corses
je vous demande de transmettre aux
hommes et aux femmes de corse
l'expression de ma considération et de
mon estime et de leur annoncer que je
compte me rendre le moment venu dans
leurs îles pour examiner avec les élus
aient eux mêmes
la solution de leurs difficultés dans un
climat débarrasser des médiocres
aventure est conforme à la fière dignité
de la corse et il m'appartient
maintenant de mettre en oeuvre
avec les préfets et mes collaborateurs
de la police de la gendarmerie avec les
collaborateurs de la centrale riz les
directives qui nous hantait des zones
voilà ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres et
déclenché cette riposte musclée du
gouvernement d'abord vous le voyez le
plasticage de l'émetteur de télévision
de bastia résultat presque toute la
corse privée de télévision et de radio
30 millions lourdes dégâts en attente a
signé flnc groupuscule clandestin prêts
à tout pour obtenir l'indépendance de
l'île est responsable de nombreux
attentats ces jours derniers pas très
loin des indépendantistes les
autonomistes légaux d'edmond simeoni
dimanche 14 ou à furiani simerini
condamné la violence il appelait
cependant ses militants à la lutte à
outrance lutte en vue d'obtenir un
statut d'autonomie interne seuls et
c'est en fait ce qui l'oppose aux
extrémistes la défense nationale et les
affaires étrangères serait laissée entre
les mains du pouvoir central
pour le reste un gouvernement corse
présidera aux destinées des insulaires
objectif internationaliser le problème
corse
jusqu'ici la population de l'île voyait
d'un oeil plutôt indifférents les
agissements de ces groupes
aujourd'hui elle commence à parler ce
n'est pas toujours pour les encourager
daniel brême donc dans sa déclaration le
chef de l'état insiste surtout sur le
dialogue avec les élus
oui il insiste sur le dialogue avec les
élus mais je voudrais préciser un peu
avant que monsieur bonnet aujourd'hui à
travailler tout l'après-midi à la mise
en place des directives du président de
la république avec les deux préfets et
les représentants des ministres
intéressés
alors pour en revenir aux propos du
président de la république je retiens en
fait trois points premièrement le
plastique ne doit en aucun cas remplacer
le scrutin des élections successives se
seront déroulées dans des conditions
démocratiques des assemblées de
tendances diverses et des majorités donc
diverses se sont dégagées les
autonomistes n'ont jamais pu obtenir dé
lui le principe du suffrage universel ou
qu'elle les français sont
démocratiquement attachés ne peut pas
être bafouée qu'on a sur la violence
exactement monsieur giscard d'estaing
deuxième point est prêt à se rendre sur
place à dialoguer avec les élus et avec
la population comme il le fait
actuellement dans
mu comme il le fera prochainement dans
les hautes-alpes mais à une condition
que le calme soit rétabli
enfin troisième point à travers la corse
le président lance en fait un appel à la
conscience de tous les français
que deviendrait leur dit-il en substance
un pays où la violence remplacerez le
dialogue démocratique et où chaque
mécontents utiliserait des moyens
illégaux pour faire aboutir ses
revendications
là en fait le président reprend un thème
qui lui est cher celui de l'unité du
pays et il appelle les français à la
réflexion merci daniel moyne monsieur de
guy ringot le ministre français des
affaires étrangères et donc sur le
chemin du retour
dans l'avion qui le ramène de tanzanie
deux jours plus tôt que prévu ils
viennent expliquer aux journalistes qui
l'accompagnent qu'il ne fallait pas
réduire son voyage en afrique à cet
incident de dar es salaam
même s'il avait une signification
politique voulue il est surtout due à
une question de protocole at il dit
visiblement donc monsieur guérin gauche
cherche à ne pas envenimer les choses
preuve supplémentaire d'ailleurs il ne
fera le compte rendu de sa tournée
africaine à monsieur giscard d'estaing
que vendredi prochain
dans une semaine la colère est passé
donc mais l'incident reste tout de même
jugez plutôt ce sont ces étudiants qui
ont provoqué l'éclat diplomatique de
monsieur bilingue
à peine descendu de l'avion le ministre
français des affaires étrangères a été
chahutée et conspué par une centaine de
manifestants hurlent en france hors
d'afrique et d'autres slogans hostiles
ministre français a vivement réagi
jugeant intolérable cette manifestation
parce qu'elle avait nécessairement
l'assentiment et l'appui du gouvernement
tanzanien dont il était l'invité le
refus des tanzaniens par la suite de
présenter des excuses ou même de
désavouer officiellement les
manifestants en est d'ailleurs une
preuve supplémentaire
c'est ce refus qui a conduit le ministre
français interrompre immédiatement sa
visite à dare et ça les manifestants
reprochaient à la france ses liens avec
l'afrique du sud
surtout pour ce qui est des ventes
d'armes et de centrales nucléaires or
bien que la france ne soit en fait que
le 6e fournisseur commercial de
l'afrique du sud loin derrière les
etats-unis et la grande-bretagne
il est vrai que 50% du matériel
militaire sud africain est d'origine
france est notamment des missiles pour
blinder des mirages des hélicoptères et
des soumah mais la plupart de ces
armements sont en fait construit sous
licence par les sud africaines
or la visite de monsieur diego en
afrique de l'est avait justement pour
objectif de marquer un changement de cap
dans la politique française vis-à-vis
des problèmes de l'afrique australe
lors de ses conversations avec samora
machel le président du mozambique ici
monsieur de birago avait réussi à
convaincre son interlocuteur que la
france était décidé à se ranger
davantage aux côtés des mouvements de
libération noir en leur fournissant par
exemple une aide humanitaire de même
robert mugabe que l'on voit ici le plus
dur des leaders nationalistes rhodésien
a reconnu après avoir rencontré monsieur
dire 1 go que la france avait changé
d'avis et de manière d'agir il est
dommage que la tanzanie n'ai pas voulu
s'en rendre compte elle aussi afin de
passer la suite ce journal bernard ap
une dernières nouvelles et oui le juge
fédéral milton polak à la requête des
avocats du port de new york du pot n'y a
accordé un délai supplémentaire de trois
jours à l'exécution de son jugement
adjointe et todd qui autorisait vous en
souvenez le concorde atterrir à new york
pour une période d'essai ainsi les
avocats ont désormais jusqu'au 30 août
pour préparer le dossier d'appel devant
la cour de new york officiel monsieur
suarez le président du conseil espagnol
viendra à paris le 31 août prochain il
sera reçu par le président de la
république et il aura des entretiens
avec le premier ministre monsieur
raymond barre en allemagne fédérale dans
la sphère cap l'heure personne n'a
encore revu l'ex chef de la gestapo de
rome
la police allemand ne sait quand même
garder la maison où il se serait réfugié
après plusieurs menaces et le craint en
effet un attentat son côté monsieur
willy brandt le président du parti
social démocrate a écrit au chancelier
schmidt pour lui expliquer ses
inquiétudes à propos de la renaissance
des activités néo nazies en allemagne
fédérale des pétards dans les rues des
affiches sur les murs de l'université de
pékin deux signes qui ne trompent pas et
qui confirme bien la fin du 11e congrès
du parti communiste chinois
ce n'est pas encore officiel ni la radio
ni la télévision de noms annoncés mais
on devrait connaître incessamment
les premiers résultats de ce congrès
particulièrement important puisque c'est
le premier depuis la mort de mao tsé
taux important en effet selon jm congrès
du parti communiste chinois qui prend
fin c'est peut-être un symbole au moment
où l'on inaugure place tienanmen le
mausolée de mao dont voici les premières
images important parce que c'est au
cours de ce congrès que l'on a arrêté de
façon définitive toute la politique
chinoise pour les années à venir
et c'est là que la sphère de vie
intéressante en fait on va sans doute
reprendre toutes les thèses de l'ancien
premier ministre
one like concernant l'avenir économique
de la chine cela veut dire que si tout
marche bien
le pays devrait être l'une des premières
puissances mondiales sur le plan
économique
avant l'an 2000 c'est une véritable
révolution dans la mesure où jusqu'à
présent on mettait en avant plutôt la
télé petit maoïstes ont préféré de
petites usines produisant peu mais où
tout le monde avait du travail
aujourd'hui on sacrifie la philosophie
et on se lance comme tout le monde dans
la course à la production on savait que
la chine allait changer après la mort de
mao
les décisions prises par le 11e congrès
le confiant
jimmy carter critiqué hier la décision
de monsieur beggin de créer en
cisjordanie trois nouvelles colonies
d'implantation juives
le gouvernement français s'est dit
aujourd'hui vivement préoccupé par la
politique israélienne dans les
territoires occupés
l'agriculture est très importante pour
l'économie française dit y être 10
acquis hier le président de la
république au cours de son voyage dans
la meuse et en particulier pour son rôle
dans le commerce extérieur
il est de fait que la france exporte une
bonne partie de sa production agricole
cette année encore les céréales vont
aider à l' équilibre de notre balance
commerciale
car comme le confirmait monsieur michel
de baptiste dans notre journal il ya
deux jours la récolte a été bonne et
cela malgré le mauvais temps
pourtant si l'on sait d'ores et déjà
qu'il y aura beaucoup de blé cette année
la baisse des cours mondiaux du blé
pourrait entraîner quelques problèmes
dans le marché commun agricole l'été
médiocre n'a pas compromis les récoltes
et producteur de céréales plus un soupir
de soulagement au moment du bilan les
méfaits de la sécheresse de l'an dernier
sont presque oubliés
même si la qualité parfois inégale la
production atteindra vraisemblablement
les chiffres record de 73 le bilan n'est
pas définitif bien sûr surtout pour le
maïs qui n'est pas encore récolté mais
on peut déjà évaluer les résultats
16 millions de tonnes pour le blé 6 pour
l'orge vraisemblablement 8 pour le maïs
et 9 pour les autres céréales au total
40 millions de tonnes
c'est sans doute peu de choses par
rapport aux 1100 millions qui seront
récoltés dans le monde cette année et
cela permet tout de même à la france de
se placer dans le peloton de tête des
pays exportateurs de céréales la france
vendra cette année plus du tiers de sa
production autant de devises qui sont
les bienvenus pour notre commerce
extérieur
ces ventes elles se feront pour moitié
aux autres pays de l'europe des neuf car
la france qui produit 40 % des céréales
de la communauté reste bien le grenier
de l'europe pour l'autre moitié le
problème sera plus délicat depuis
plusieurs années les cours mondiaux du
blé ont beaucoup baissé malgré des
besoins accrus dans le monde entier
cette baisse des cours mondiaux elle est
amorcée depuis à peu près deux ans à la
suite d'une période où le blé a été
effectivement très cher parce
très demandée par un certain nombre de
pays on se souvient certainement d'achat
important de la russie de la chine
quelques autres pays à la suite donc de
ces demandes importantes un pays comme
les etats-unis a reconverti une partie
de ses terres vers le blé la production
a été très belle les deux récoltes
précédentes pour ce pays et bien sûr
maintenant les marchés montait au
souffre d'une offre qui est beaucoup
trop importante
cette baisse des cours mondiaux n'aura
pas pousser cause directe sur le revenu
des agriculteurs
le système de l'europe verte compense la
différence entre le cours mondial et le
prix européen en reversant des aides
financières aux producteurs et c'est un
système qui ne peut sans doute pas durer
éternellement car ils coûtent cher à la
communauté
si la baisse des cours du blé se
poursuivent et les producteurs français
serait sans doute obligée de reconvertir
une partie de leur production
sinon les tensions entre les différents
pays du marché commun agricole pourrait
bien s'aggraver bonne récolte donc pour
les céréales cette année les moissons
sont pratiquement terminés heureusement
d'ailleurs car le temps a fait grise
mine ces dernières semaines les nuages
i les pluies de ces derniers jours
n'aurait pas arrangé les affaires des
agriculteurs la plupart du temps
aujourd'hui on utilise des machines pour
couper pour battre le blé jeudi la
plupart du temps car dans le maine et
loire en particulier dans le village
d'angrie les habitants ont essayé de
faire un petit retour aux sources
il s'était réservé une pièce de blé un
hectare pour faire les moissons à
l'ancienne
autrefois pour les moissons ou
seigneurie on venait des quatre coins du
village et même de la région entière
personne n'était de trop on avait besoin
de bras c'était avant tout la solidarité
entre paysans même si elle était parfois
un peu forcé il fallait bien s'entraider
personne n'était de trop pour donner la
main comme on disait à la crau paille
mais ce n'était pas vraiment la fête car
le labeur étaient dures ces moissons à
l'ancienne on les pratique et encore il
n'y a pas si longtemps
jusque vers les années 1950 la
signification d'une fête comme celle ci
c'est tout simplement de faire revivre
une époque totalement révolue et de
faire connaître aux jeunes qui ont
vraiment accroché comment nos aînés
autrefois travaillé faucheuse javeleuse
moissonneuses javeleuse moissonneuses
batteuses tout un vocabulaire qui
appartient pas c'est bien révolu les
angry on a sorti des hangars de ce passé
où tout n'était pas facile tout un
arsenal qui une fois bien huilée s'est
remis à marcher à merveille
on va racheter en pas
du battage au fléau au battage avec
manèges à quatre chevaux voici le fruit
du dur travail des moissonneurs les
grains de blé briller calibré seul
résultat tangible d'une richesse
rudement amassés
et comme dans toute fête il y à une
attraction vedette ici c'est la machine
à vapeur ou locaux mobile relié à la
batteuse restaurée dans ses moindres
détails d'une précision d'horloge et
malgré son aspect de pièces de musée
elle marchait encore dans bon nombre de
campagnes il y à seulement 20 ans
oui
alors curiosité folklore bien sûr mais
cette notion actuelle de fait ne
cache-t-elle pas en réalité la misère
des paysans d'autrefois et plus encore
n'est-ce pas la nostalgie d'un temps où
la mécanisation à outrance ne régnait
pas encore en maître absolu sur le
travail des hommes échange assez vif
entre georges marchais et monsieur
raymond barre à propos du parisien
libéré
georges marchais se félicitait de la
victoire des ouvriers du parisien libéré
dû au fait que des cellules communistes
étaient implantés dans tous les
quotidiens de paris le premier ministre
répond il s'indigne de cet aveu il
considère cela comme une grave menace
contre la liberté de la presse
le gouvernement veillera dit raymond
barre à faire respecter la liberté et le
pluralisme des moyens d'expression en
france
innovation à la rentrée un dossier
scolaire suivra les lèvres pendant tout
au long de sa scolarité c'est officiel
depuis ce matin pratiquement cela se
passera comme ça l'équipe éducative
c'est à dire les enseignants les
psychologues les médecins et le
personnel de direction remplira ce
dossier avec des renseignements sur les
lèvres
c'est à dire état civil santé etc le
dossier sera constituée à partir de la
maternelle jusqu'en 3e les parents et
les élèves majeurs pourront le consulter
mais pas les futurs employeurs en
afrique du sud fantastique vol de
diamants 280000 pierre d'une valeur de
près de 2 milliards ont été dérobés au
propriétaire d'une entreprise de taille
de diamant la police sud africaine a
lancé une chasse à l'homme pour
retrouver les trois auteurs de ce vol
pour l'instant aucune trace des trois
voleurs et puis vous vous souvenez du
vol sacrilège de la cathédrale d'oviedo
60 milliards de butin est bien une
partie des joyaux ont été récupérés
aujourd'hui dans la serviette d'un
voyageur qui essayaient de passer au
portugal
walter folie n'est pas l'assassin
les deux britanniques retrouvés
sauvagement tués dans leur voiture près
de saint tropez
trois témoins l'avais reconnue deux
autres l'ont complètement disque
p que se serait-il passé pour walter
folie d'ailleurs si une jeune femme
n'était pas venu dire au juge qu'il
avait passé la nuit avec elle cela pose
bien le problème éternel de la fragilité
des témoignages dans ce genre d'affaires
c'est ce qu'explique en particulier le
juge d'instruction qui a décidé
l'élargissement de valter avec l'accord
de mon collègue du parquet il a été
décidé de mettre fin à ces tensions et
j'ai donc pris une ordonnance de main
levée du mandat de dépôt
mais quand on voit leur folie est
l'objet d'une procédure devant le
tribunal correctionnel de nice
il reste détenu en vertu du mandat de
dépôt du procureur de la république de
nice et il sera transféré aujourd'hui
même à la maison d'arrêt de nice
finalement est-ce que ça peut être un
peu prématuré cette inculpation il ya 48
heures et plus aujourd'hui cet
élargissement la question effectivement
on peut se poser
il existait contre walter folie des
charges puisque trois témoins l'avait
formellement identifié comme étant la
personne qui avait mangé à côté du
groupe de touristes britanniques
quelques heures avant le crime compte
tenu des charges estimé que je ne peux
plus d'entendre comme témoin vous avez
joué trois témoins contre 2,12 la
fragilité sur lequel reposaient toutes
les enquêtes alors pourquoi croire les
uns et par les autres
et bien parce que les témoins les
témoignages a le même nom qu'une portée
relative
ce qui est très important ce sont les
éléments matériels et qui peuvent
concrétiser corroborer le témoignage
or si ce qui s'est passé mais les trois
premiers témoins physiquement lors
reconnue mais l'autre le dernier témoin
a pu donner des précisions qui se sont
avérées exactes qui ont été vérifiés
dean fait aucun doute
walter folie se trouvait bien 8 au soir
à nice et non pas réel konaté
est-ce qu'on est passé à côté d'une
erreur judiciaire
eh bien peut-être parce que
effectivement sur les sur la foi des
témoignages aussi concordants aussi
formel peut-être peut-être l'inculpé
aurait pu être condamné pour les crimes
qui finalement ne vaut pas commis et par
conséquent il vaut mieux que les choses
soient précises comme cela les obsèques
d'elvis presley nalu dernière à memphis
au tennessee
un peu à l'image des derniers mois de sa
vie des dizaines de milliers
d'admirateurs et d'admiratrices était là
mais ils n'ont pas participé à la
cérémonie tout s'est passé loin du
public
seuls quelques intimes des personnalités
john wayne burt reynolds ont accompagné
le convoi funèbre
les gardes du corps aussi un enterrement
qui a ressemblé par bien des détails à
ceux des grands caïds américains à
commencer par les quinze cadillac
blanche
elvis le king traverse sa ville
une dernière fois vêtue de blanc comme
il l'avait souhaité
la foule de ses fans de tous les âges
venus du texas de l'illinois où de
l'alabama qui tant de fois lui a hurlé
son admiration lui rend aujourd'hui un
hommage silencieux
pas d'incident notoire la police
craignait le pire après les scènes
d'hystérie auquel on avait assisté
mercredi devant les grilles de la grande
maison à colonnes après les cérémonies à
graceland dans le public a été écartée
le cortège des cadillac conduisant les
amis d'elvis comme georges vanier burthe
reynolds ainsi que son ex femme et sa
fille peut atteindre le somptueux
mausolée de forest hill dans la dignité
plus de deux mille couronnes gerbe
guitare fleury témoignent de l'immense
affection des américains pour leur idole
c'est dans un cercueil de cuir portés
par les quelques familiers qui ont
toujours dressé des murailles autour de
sa vie privée
quelle vie se reposera aux côtés de sa
mère pour tous ceux qui ont fredonné
love me tender ou danser sur don't be
cruel memphis est devenu depuis quelques
jours la ville la plus triste l'immonde
un front mon pétrolier qui dit mieux
c'est le propriétaire de l'olympique
bravery le supertanker échoué sur l'île
d'ouessant qui a proposé ce marché un
franc tope là a dit un entrepreneur
marseillais qui a acheté le bateau pour
cette somme symbolique il va le découper
en morceaux en sport il ya du football
ce soir à la fiche la 4e journée du
championnat de france de football match
vedette saint-etienne nice
et puis à suivre tout particulièrement
aussi le match monaco strasbourg monaco
qui était encore en deuxième division
l'année dernière et qui est en tête du
championnat et qui pourrait fort bien
encore y rester ce soir bref l'équipe
surprise de ce début de saison
thierry roland est allé voir sur place
dans la principauté pour essayer de
découvrir les secrets de cette réussite
monaco au mois d'août respire surtout un
air de vacances monaco c'est le rocher
les plages le casino ou encore le palais
princier
mais c'est aussi l'équipe de football de
l'association sportive de monaco grande
révélation de ce début de saison
après avoir joué l'an passé en deuxième
division l'as monaco vient de faire deux
remarquables débuts en première division
remportant ses trois premiers matchs
marquant huit buts sans en concéder un
seul l'entraîneur de l'équipe c'est
lucien leduc qui fut l'entraîneur de
monaco il ya 15 ans lorsque l'équipe de
la principauté réussi le fameux doublé
coupe-championnat sur le vu des trois
matches que nous avons fait il y a eu
évidemment disant des similitudes
quoique les joueurs sont évidemment
disons différents quoi vous savez aussi
que cette équipe a été modifié presque
par moitié il ya eu cinq joueurs
nouveaux qui sont vu trois joueurs de
1re division et de joueur de deuxième
division et les amalgames a eu l'air de
se faire rapidement
parlez nous de ces de ses nouveaux
joueurs on est surpris par exemple de
voir un garçon comme noguès libéré par
marseille c'est un très bon joueur
oui noguez c'est un très bon joueur il
est évident que ces joueurs d'ailleurs
moi je ne les ai pas suivi disons à la
trace comme autre joueur de première
division il y avait garé dont jaillit la
gare donc est venue de lille est un
excellent en stoppeur que j'avais vu
jouer il ya
deux ans n'est ce pas en outre courbit
ce que j'avais connu en tant que junior
comme lorsque j'étais à l'olympique de
marseille
malheureusement pour lui ses blessés
d'ailleurs avant le premier match où
deuxième match et deuxième match amical
que nous avons fait je sais pas mais il
a repris l'entraînement et en ce qui
concerne les joueurs de 2e division
nous avons moins ans qui viennent ont
volé mais qui est un réel espoir du
chômage record et bonne marge de
progression intéressante
il y à aussi delio onnis le buteur un
argentin qui marque 25 buts par an
christian d'alger qui vient d'être
retenu en équipe de france sans oublier
les deux gardiens yves chauveau l'ancien
et jean luc ettori 23 ans le nouveau une
équipe homogène qui fait très plaisir à
son capitaine jean petit résultat de
tous ses matches de la 4e journée donc
dans le journal de bernard rapp vers
22h25 ce soir sur antenne 2 la météo
pour demain maintenant demain samedi
pluies et orages le matin de la bretagne
aux pyrénées au golfe du lion cette
pluie ces orages gagneront ensuite le
reste du pays ou l'aggravation se
développera après des éclaircies
matinales
cette zone sera suivi sur l'ouest et le
sud ouest par un temps variable avec des
averses ou des orages accompagnés de
vents assez fort avec des rafales et
puis seront abondantes du massif central
au jura et aux alpes
dimanche le temps sera médiocre et
relativement frais sur la plupart des
régions pour terminer cette édition nous
allons verser maintenant une larme n'ont
pas de crocodile mais une larme de
coccinelles sept automobiles construites
par volkswagen en 1936 et dont la firme
allemande a décidé d'arrêter la
production en décembre prochain
en guise d'adieu voici un extrait d'un
film américain le troisième de la série
produit par walt disney il sortira en
février prochain en france
il nous vous le présentons donc en
première exclusivité
je souhaite un très beau week-end voici
ce que peut faire une coccinelle
le pack
il a tout faux